[Música]
oi eu acabei de sair de uma crise
existencial
na verdade eu passei recentemente por
ela e conseguiu sobreviver
eu tinha me separado de uma pessoa que
eu amo muito e era um casamento que eu
achava que ia durar pra sempre
eu achava que a gente ia ficar velhinha
junto pra piorar ele ia fazer 40 anos e
aquilo estava me deixando absolutamente
fritada eu me achava muito velha para
recomeçar qualquer coisa eu sei que essa
não é a melhor maneira de se apresentar
para alguém ou de começar uma conversa
mas eu descobri que quando você fala
daquilo que é verdadeiro para você as
suas chances de se conectar com alguém
através da verdade dela aumenta quer ver
por exemplo eu queria saber quantas
pessoas aqui no seu auditório eu teria
uma conversa muito boa por conta dessa
conexão da verdade
levanta a mão quem já teve crise
existencial
quem está no meio da crise pode levantar
a mão também quem não tem coragem de
admitir também pode levantar é duro né
crise existencial
eu vivi muito forte e som
eu fiquei deprimida eu desenvolvi uma
doença auto-imune eu comecei a acreditar
que eu tinha perdido a capacidade de me
conectar comigo mesmo com as pessoas que
me amavam principalmente com aquelas
pessoas que não conhece ainda com os
outros eu virei um pano de chão em um
clássico né acontece quando você vira um
pano de chão todo mundo vem com rodo
amiga vão para a balada esquece isso
bobagem
minha filha é thomas e sal grosso aqui ó
lado direito a ser uma beleza
não vou ali que você tem que meditar
sete dias e sete noites na lua cheia
depois e corta o cabelo vai dar tudo
certo e é por amor que as pessoas fazem
isso não é por maldade mas todos esses
planos que passaram por que você tá
lança um pano de chão se vai né
um desses pra mim fez muito sentido que
foi a minha irmã que me conhece muito o
que me disse 'vai da áfrica e eu aqui
foi sentido pra mim porque eu imaginava
que viajar sozinha seja uma oportunidade
incrível de conhecer pessoas
eu também poderia passar meus 40 anos
bem longe
e aí eu terei a oportunidade de me
conectar com as pessoas novas e talvez
porque não comigo mesmo e fui enfim
apesar das pessoas acharem que aquilo
não fazia nenhum sentido que eu comprei
uma passagem transando e embarquei nessa
viagem sem ter feito nenhum planejamento
eu não sabia nada sobre os meus destinos
mas eu tinha certeza que eram as pessoas
que eu conheci nessa viagem que é
ensinar sobre cultura sobre os costumes
que elas gostavam de ouvir onde elas
comiam quais eram os hobbies como é o
trabalho delas elas iam deixar minha
viagem mais rica muito mais do que se eu
tivesse lido simplesmente um guia de
viagem
então eu coloquei pra mim a seguinte
missão de conhecer muitas pessoas
interessantes
e é com essa mesma intenção que eu
gostaria de convidar vocês aqui hoje
para fazer essa jornada comigo e passar
por essa experiência onde eu aprendi dos
sonhos fundamentais pra você conhecer
pessoas interessantes
você está sim então vamos lá eu peço um
chapéu eu faço uma mochilinha
eu pego minha passagem transamba e vou
pro aeroporto
eu chego no aeroporto e diz passar a
bagagem e entrou no avião quando chegou
num avião eu procuro o meu lugar e
quando eu cheguei no meu lugar tem um
gringo tem bonitão que se levanta propor
deitar e winter daquele sorriso amarelo
obrigada siga na poltrona coloco sinto
relaxo dia
o problema é que quando você viaja para
dar um tempo de você você vai junto
e não é que você vai junto calado
meditando você vai junto dando palpite
e aí karina língua bonitão vai falar com
ele pra que eu vou falar com ele
conhecer pessoas têm que falar com ele
essa viagem
a viagem não começou o avião ainda a
viagem já começou está no avião é por
isso só na áfrica vou falar com ele eu
não vou sair daqui enquanto você não
fala com ele tá bom eu vou falar com ele
eu vou falar com ele
marina eu estou vivendo o avião e eu
pensei pra caramba eu tinha uma idéia
genial
eu olhei pra ele disse em from sabe que
ele disse estava dormindo
dez horas depois o dorminhoco concorda
a gente começa a conversar e me deu o
cartão dele me convida para tomar um
vinho quando estivesse passando pela
cidade onde ele mora
eu pego meu caminho ele pego dele a
gente se despede e desembarque na zâmbia
e na áfrica
como eu não sabia o que ia acontecer
como é que eu ia conversar com essas
pessoas
levei umas cartas elas funcionavam mais
ou menos como um jogo eu queria
comprovar a minha teoria de que se você
começa uma conversa com uma pergunta
interessante
as chances da sua conversas e também
interessante aumento é algumas perguntas
eram assim
esse dinheiro não fosse um problema como
você veria o você tem alguma superstição
qual foi a última vez que você chorou de
tanto rir e eu estava ali justamente
pensando isso dentro de um ônibus
atravessando a fronteira entre a zâmbia
e botsuana quando eu conheci um casal de
americanos que estavam ali
acreditem comemorando seus 40 anos de
casados eles se olhava nos olhos pra
contrariar todas as minhas crenças a
respeito de um casamento
eles eram super apaixonados e sérgio
dominava eles não davam demandada era
super esquisito aproximei dele e
perguntei vocês topariam fazer esse
ferimento e usou uma pesquisadora eu
queria fazer uma estátua para foram
incríveis ea a a primeira pergunta que
ela puxou pra ele foi
você se arrepende de não ter feito
alguma coisa na sua vida por medo
ele diz que sim ele disse que ele se
arrependia de eles não terem mudado a
austrália quando eles tiveram a
oportunidade e aí começa uma conversa e
ainda entre os dois sobre os medos as
frustrações
a implicância da tomada de decisão
daquela tomada de decisão na vida deles
pra completar eles começaram a falar
mas por que a gente não vai protestar e
agora nossos filhos tão grande nossos
países estão bem e foi maravilhoso e
choraram e se abraçaram e óbvio né
andavam demandada então foi incrível e
dessas conversas eu tive muitas e foi
maravilhoso mas teve uma personagem lá
que me marcou muito
é no senhor há perdão esqueci de falar
essa taxa é a primeira lição que aprendi
você tem que fazer perguntas
interessantes quando você conclui que
fim quando você começa uma conversa
fazendo perguntas interessantes as
chances da sua conversa ser mais
profunda mais interessante elas aumentam
muito bem vamos aqui há um personagem
dessa história
o senhor me fechada eu tinha acabado de
chegar num lugar novo eu não conhecia
ninguém
então eu tava meio mal humorada meio do
dida é será eu sentada jantando sozinho
credibilidade crise existencial
recém-separada um amor total à minha
frente um casal jantava eu não conseguia
ver o rosto dela e só via ele
eles não se falavam apenas comiam em
silêncio
eu olhei aquela cena pensei morado né
pra que a gente tomou lugar tão bonito
é óbvio que é porque eles são casados há
uns 60 anos deve ser isso
eu prefiro mil vezes está aqui cantando
sozinha do que com um homem com quem eu
não converso
naquele momento eu transformei me fez
xales no meu bode espiatório aonde ele
ia e ficava olhando quanto mal humorado
ele era então entendeu como aquilo
reverberava dentro de mim muito bem eu
queria rapidamente fazer um experimento
aqui com a gente sobre uma coisa bem
interessante pode acender a luz
aí ia pedir pra vocês por favor dar uma
boa olhada
sabe aquela pescoço assim quando chega
na balada pra ver quem está na bola
daqui é daquelas escaneado por favor
[Música]
muito bem e agora posso pedir para vocês
se apresentar em uns para os outros
assim mesmo que você já conheça se
apresenta para pessoa
ótimo
léo apagar o que aconteceu agora nesses
pequenos segundos foi que o nosso
cérebro fez milhares de conexões
eu posso garantir que muitas dessas
conexões foram os julgamentos
isso é do ser humano gente é quase
impossível evitar o julgamento e o que
estava fazendo comerciais charles estava
julgando ele estava jogando ele sem
sequer ter trocado uma palavra
nós ficamos o mesmo grupo de passeios e
conforme o dia ea passando eu vi que ele
era muito tímido e sensível ele ficava
observando os passarinhos enquanto
estava todo mundo buscando leões
elefantes
naquela mesma noite a companheira dele
veio até mim e me disse eu vi que você
tá andando sozinho há algum tempo você
gostaria de sentar junto com a gente
hoje ó eu tive que sair do meu status
solitária e para julgar ele e tomar
coragem sair da minha zona de conforto
mas afinal tinha ido lá pra isso então
me sinto em a mesa e foi jantar como
bode expiatório da austrália eles não
eram casados
eles tinham acabado de se conhecer um
site de relacionamentos
ele nasceu no zimbábue lugar de onde ele
saiu fugido depois de ter lutado na
guerra civil da rodésia
naquela mesma savana onde a gente andava
com os nossos ditos barulhentos
segurando câmeras fotográficas
ele também já tinha andado por ali mas
impunham uma arma e rezando para não ser
morto por um inimigo
ele andava em silêncio por causa disso
para não ser descoberto
era por isso que ele sabia tanto sobre
os passarinhos eo me dei conta que ele
não estava mal humorado ele só estava
profundamente emocionado o que
aconteceria se eu tivesse ficado só no
meu lugar no meu cantinho julgando foi
logo é o bode expiatório que deixou
minha viagem mais rica e ele me ensinou
sobre os costumes locais sobre a comida
ele me ensinou algumas palavras em
chonan que é uma das línguas que se fala
ali eu experience ei eu vivi eu saí de
um patamar cultural e fui pra outro
tudo isso por causa de uma pessoa com
quem me conectei e essa foi a segunda
lição que aprendi
já que a gente não pode evitar já que é
muito difícil evitar o julgamento que a
gente evite ao máximo a sentença porque
quando a gente se entende se alguém a
gente perde a chance do maravilhoso que
é o universo do outro
eu aprendi que a vida é uma experiência
compartilhada com o mundo com os outros
e com nós mesmos só queria mostrar pra
vocês
a última foto que o filho do meu da
minha viagem eu conhecia a cidade do
cabo na garupa de uma moto
adivinha uma moto de quem é eu fui tomar
que ele venha
também
[Música]
e além de conhecer a cidade do cabo na
garupa de uma moto
eu vi uma paixão e mais legal mais legal
disso é que ninguém precisa ir para a
áfrica para conhecer pessoas
interessantes
a gente pode se beneficiar disso agora
nesse instante aqui mesmo aqui mesmo
por isso eu quero pedir a vocês que
saiam daqui hoje sabendo que essa pessoa
que está ali do seu lado
tem alguma coisa muito interessante pra
te dizer já que a gente está consciente
dos nossos julgamentos por que não
pensar em alguma coisa a fazer uma
pergunta interessante para ela
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]